[Music]
foreign
ER has given us a very important mission
for tonight Target is across the street
we must we must use stealth and cutting
to infiltrate the human world and
retrieve
Gogurt
okay Batman what I'm just trying to Hype
you guys up okay that list okay what
else are we getting four
clothes yeah I like cheese it was very
specific think about the party size he
underlined it twice all right Donnie
you're on toiletries RAF you're stocking
up the pantry and Mikey you're on
junkers and remember don't let any human
see you because why you maybe are the
demon scum of the earth
and hey I know that's objectively
prejudiced but that's what Dad taught us
uh I think humans seem kind of cool to
be honest Beyonce that guy's the goat
I'd love to have a champagne brunch with
Tom Brady I fear he seems like a fun
Hank and I've always wanted to go to
flavor Town look we all think humans are
cool but we got a job to do let's go
bronchitis
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
don't use that word that way I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we take out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool
I can't believe there are other mutants
you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
can't stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my door
my son Michelangelo you have heart
Donatello you have wisdom rapper F you
have bravery and Leonardo honored
I dream about fighting every night you
've got rage
[Music]
thank you